[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti certo il mondo
dell'opera può sembrare un mondo lontano
eppure noi
scopriremo oggi come invece è
incredibilmente vicino a noi come ci
appartiene come fa parte dei linguaggi
del nostro tempo e come partecipa al
rinnovamento dello spettacolo e delle
arti
innanzitutto vorrei farvi capire come un
oggetto che sembra così lontano distante
antico può essere uno straordinario
laboratorio aperto di energie creative
dove reagiscono e si trovano energie
fermenti di linguaggi artistici
contemporanei che vanno dal suono
l'immagine al movimento allo spazio
all'immagine elettronica la videoarte al
canto naturalmente per diventare uno
spettacolo incredibilmente attuale che
cosa ci vuole prima di tutto per creare
questo laboratorio un bel teatro un
teatro come questo questo è il teatro
comunale di bologna il teatro di questa
città è uno dei più bei teatri del mondo
con un'acustica leggendaria ma
soprattutto è un gioiello di
architettura del 1700
creato nel 1763 dall'archi star
dell'epoca antonio galli bibiena così
come è stato concepito realizzato è
rimasto fino ai giorni nostri mai
danneggiato è un teatro che ha
un'acustica straordinaria perché quella
architetto ha voluto che fosse uno
strumento straordinario una specie di
grande aiuto che risuona e che può
creare armonia e atmosfere sonore
immensamente belle questo teatro è
arrivato fino a noi noi lo ereditiamo lo
prendiamo e vogliamo trasformarlo in
quel laboratorio di contemporaneità di
cui vi ho parlato un teatro che ha
queste caratteristiche ha bisogno di
avere all'interno dei grandi elementi
artistici
il primo di questi è un orchestra
un'orchestra è uno straordinario
elemento un progetto sonoro una
straordinaria energia sonora che si
propaga
da tanti strumenti che suonano assieme
che concertano assieme appunto che
lavorano assieme ogni giorno ognuno per
la sua parte per creare quello che si
chiama una sinfonia ovvero l'arte di
suonare assieme e la musica e l'arte di
mettere tutte queste cose assieme
un'arte come quella che abbiamo visto
appartiene al lavoro dei laboratori che
appartiene al lavoro dell'equipe ecco il
teatro è una grande equipe è un grande
laboratorio dove un'equipe di artisti ed
i professionisti della musica lavora
insieme un'orchestra è senz'altro il
motore principale di questo grande
laboratorio e poi che cosa serve un coro
un m un gruppo di voci importanti che si
uniscono agli strumenti per entrare
all'interno di questa grande fabbrica di
produzione sonoro sonora una fabbrica di
suoni di immagini di sogni ma
soprattutto di emozioni
ecco quello che è un teatro d'opera ecco
come dobbiamo guardarlo dobbiamo
guardarla proprio con questa idea che la
musica del passato
la musica di mozart verdi rossini
bellini donizetti puccini wagner e poi
via via fino al nostro tempo è qualcosa
che appartiene uno spettacolo
incredibilmente moderno e dopo vediamo
perché quest'opera è incredibilmente
moderna ci vuole un'altra cosa perché
questo laboratorio sia completo un
palcoscenico un palcoscenico con dei
tecnici che lavorano per creare queste
straordinarie emozioni per creare queste
straordinarie come possiamo dire
vibrazioni che diventano figure che
diventano scena che diventano immagini
che diventano storia che diventano
racconto un racconto che ci riguarda
pensate ad esempio alle opere di
giuseppe verdi
pensate ad esempio a un'opera come
rigoletto un'opera che mette in scena un
gobbo è qualcosa che appartiene
quest'opera ha una grandissima
rivoluzione alle grandi rivoluzioni
sociali
entrano in scena i poveri entrano in
scena i derelitti entrano in scena gli
oppressi gli emarginati
erano oltre e quasi due secoli fa quando
quest'opera veniva composta poco meno di
due secoli fa
insomma un era un mondo diverso un mondo
in cui gli oppressi non avevano mai
avuto la qualifica di protagonisti
rigoletto è un gobbo la traviata è una
prostituta azzurra la zingara del
trovatore appunto e possiamo dire
un'extracomunitaria oggi diremmo bene
non sono i semidei non sono di semidei
di wagner
non sono i grandi eroi sono un'umanità
vicino a noi
e pensate queste opere come ci parlano
che cosa ci raccontano nel ruolo che
ancora è così importante oggi del
rapporto tra le clan dei ruoli così
importanti oggi dei rapporti tra le
classi sociali e gli emarginati
sono opere che continuano a raccontare
le loro storie
nel nostro tempo e noi ascoltandoli
capiamo meglio chi siamo
capiamo meglio le nostre condizioni
capiamo meglio la nostra storia di
uomini nel nostro tempo della nostra
società e ci aiutano a entrare in certi
meccanismi che forse avevamo dato per
assodato che forse non abbiamo troppo
presenti e in più questa musica una
musica meravigliosa una musica che ci
sono ancora attuale
quando ascoltiamo la queste opere
troviamo per esempio le radici di tanta
musica popolare il tanto rock pop jazz
che ascoltiamo tutti i giorni nel
bombardamento acustico di cui siamo
vittime anche inconsapevoli sapete le
orecchie non hanno palpebre e quindi non
possiamo difenderci così chiudendo gli
occhi nello stesso momento in cui
chiudiamo le orecchie invece al
contrario
l'opera ci fa ad entrare nel mondo
straordinario dei suoni ci dice
ascoltate è un invito all'ascolto
è un invito andare verso una musica che
non è mai banale a una musica che
scopriamo e scoprirla ci dà anche l'idea
di essere dei veri esploratori
esploratori del suono
ecco quello che noi dovremmo diventare
esploratori del suono in una città
aperta
questa e bologna è una bellissima città
nel cui cuore c'è un teatro
straordinario che produce opere ed
emozioni
una città aperta e così come il teatro è
aperto e deve essere aperto ai cittadini
a tutti i protagonisti della società di
oggi non più come una volta
un teatro d'opera soltanto per pochi un
teatro d'opera per tutti dove andare a
imparare ascoltare vivere emozioni che
non abbiamo mai vissuto e quindi un
teatro per gli studenti
un teatro che oggi dove i giovani oggi
agli studenti devono diventare
protagonisti protagonisti di un pubblico
del futuro che si appropria di questo
genere in tutta europa oggi i giovani
affollano i teatri d'opera perché
l'opera è diventata la nuova chiave
dello spettacolo intermediale guardate
non uso la parola multimediale e non è
un caso
multimedialità vuol dire vendere
prodotti vendere oggetti che hanno più
media che possono esprimersi
contemporaneamente intermedialità vuol
dire usare la multimedialità la
multimedialità come linguaggio vuol dire
creare dei progetti nuovi dove i media
lavorano come progetto di una nuova
forma d'arte
l'arte intermediale e l'opera è l'arte
intermediale del nostro tempo
ecco cosa può diventare un teatro
d'opera anche un grande contenitore è
stato the dix anche a portare queste
tematiche al teatro comunale di bologna
in un recentissimo incontro un grande
incontro le tematiche dell'economia
della società devono entrare nel teatro
d'opera e quindi nuovi strati sociali
anche quelli emarginati di cui parlava
verdi oggi sono parte del nostro tempo
devono essere in un teatro che anche per
loro che li accoglie che gli racconta
che gli spiega quello che va che viene
messo in scena e quindi i nuovi media
dicevo un'arte intermediale un
palcoscenico magnificamente aperto a
queste forme dove schermi elementi dello
spazio musica elettronica dialogano con
gli strumenti d'orchestra e con quel
coro che aveva visto che avete visto
prima e poi il teatro che può uscire
naturalmente perché il teatro non è
teatro soltanto di un luogo fisico ma il
teatro di tutti di tutti e di tutti gli
spazi ecco quindi che l'opera può
invadere le piazze e luoghi pubblici
le strade i portici tutto questo fa
parte di un diverso modo di vivere e di
ascoltare il teatro d'opera che deve
essere vissuto proprio come una nuova
centrale di energia artistica e creativa
ora vediamo questo in questo in questa
immagine vediamo una bellissima
realizzazione nostra quel signore si
chiama ildebrando d'arcangelo è uno dei
più importanti bassi del nostro tempo e
sembra dire venite a teatro e
soprattutto sembra invitare tutti quelli
che sono esterni a far parte a
partecipare a questo rito questo era
attila di giuseppe verdi che certo è un
è stato un grande conquistatore di
istruttore ma noi vorremmo invece che
fosse il simbolo di questo nuovo inizio
di questo new beginning anche nel mondo
del teatro dell'opera e ora vediamo
quello che può succedere
mettendo insieme su un palcoscenico
tanti giovani questa è una traviata
realizzata con i giovani della scuola
dell'opera del teatro comunale di
bologna un centro di formazione che fa
capire come oggi lavorare con i giovani
significa mettere nuova creatività
all'interno del grande repertorio
repertorio classico energie nuove
repertorio del passato però azione
scenica nuova e così nell'azione scenica
ritroveremo anche i nuovi suoni perché
l'opera non finisce con verdi puccini
wagner eccetera ma arriva fino ai giorni
nostri oggi i compositori scrivono opera
e adesso andiamo a vedere proprio gli
aspetti creativi
questo è un bellissimo progetto che
abbiamo fatto recentemente e che è uno
dei più importanti autori del mondo si
chiama bob wilson uno dei più grandi
registi artisti creatori designer che ha
messo in scena non niente popò di meno
che macbeth di giuseppe verdi
lo vediamo subito guardate come si trova
a completare l'opera come se fosse un
oggetto d arte contemporanea e di design
questi sono il foro che complotta per
uccidere balzo nel macbeth
[Musica]
guardate questo oggetto che sale c'è un
grande artista di oggi che si chiama
elia sony sembra quasi un oggetto creato
da una sosta come li ascolta un disco
[Musica]
troppo
e guardate la linea di laser davanti di
neon laser che sembra creare un
diaframma ideale tra la scena il buio e
naturalmente il pubblico è una specie di
soglia una specie di gates che separa il
mondo della fiction dal mondo della
realtà ma al tempo stesso li unisce in
una specie di grande architettura
luminosa questo era bob wilson un grande
artista che diventa protagonista di
un'opera di grande repertorio come
macbeth di verdi e ora vediamo un po il
prossimo dicevo di questo palcoscenico
dove reagiscono le energie
ecco su questo palcoscenico reagiscono
che hanno creato e la contemporanea
e non viene abbassata e le divisioni
un'opera che parla dei monili che non
sono solo muri fisici ma sono anche
ideali culturali
questo è david moss uno dei più grandi
giornalisti del nostro tempo
[Musica]
dai graffitisti personaggi che
combattano chiusure che combattere
questo è un territorio che diventa
radice di qualità una buona musica
il compositore come andrea molino che ha
scritto quest'opera che diventa una
reale opera come possiamo dire di
presenza anche combattente su un teatro
d'opera e di protesta qui non c'è perché
ora veniamo all'ultimo dei degli esempi
che volevo farvi vedere sull'opera di
oggi sull'opera come linguaggio
intermediale si tratta dell'opera il
suono giallo un testo di kandinsky
interpretato da alessandro solbiati un
compositore di oggi con le scene create
da gianni dessì un altro artista uno dei
protagonisti dell'arte contemporanea
[Musica]
ecco vedete che il teatro diventa
veramente qualcosa di molto simile a un
progetto d'arte totale
si parlava già di arte totale nell'opera
ma oggi diventa qualcosa di diverso
diventa un'arte che interpreta anche le
tensioni psicologiche i ritmi interiori
le pulsazioni di tutto quello che ci
accade intorno
ci fa pensare e ci fa capire che l'opera
è veramente il linguaggio che guarda
verso il futuro che solo capello
messaggio solo appropriandosi di questo
messaggio si può capire davvero come
l'opera possa innovare non possa portare
l'arte il linguaggio anche quello visivo
anche quello cinematografico anche
quello sonoro
verso un nuovo territorio verso un nuovo
inizio
adesso appunto una nuova frontiera
con questo vi voglio lasciare e vi
ringrazio di avermi ascoltato
[Applauso]